[Music]
what's up guys it's david dobrik and
today i'm playing zoom around the room
on the kelly clarkson show basically the
works is they're available
[Music]
hand sanitizer slimy
right i think this counts
what else do i do you better be in this
video i'm not doing this by myself if
you're not in it i'm i'm i'm done
no is there anything else you want to
explain about it
yeah it kills 99.9 percent of bacteria
you want me to sell you on this
i'm hand sanitized oh like i
the handset i love hand sanitizer
[Music]
how he sent me this he said he said to
david best wishes howie
how cool is that that's insane this is
when he was younger
actually i can't even tell how old he
could be he could be 20 here or he could
be 60.
that's the magic about howie he gave me
that photo because i think he was um
he told me he had a big gift for me and
then he and then he he told me he had a
big gift for me and then he pulled in
like this brand new car
and he was like i'm just kidding it's
this um so he tricked me with the car
but
the photo wasn't good which i actually
like genuinely prefer the photo i love
like
little like silly things like that or
like a friend will sign something check
this out
this new memory this new merch just came
out
i love all my merch but this one
specifically i'm really excited about
we did this for my 24th birthday it says
vlog number 24 and this is the day of my
24th birthday that's a bucket hat
who doesn't look cool
[Music]
this actually i
oh i sure got the couch i couldn't have
picked it up
this mirror you'd be surprised how
expensive mirrors are
and this one was probably around 400 how
much was it
400 a thousand a thousand dollars
that's the most expensive thing didn't
you just post about some crazy
like suit that you got
oh
[Music]
my god
yeah but it's in the garage it takes me
like 25 minutes to put on
oh you think i just put the shades on
all of a sudden it comes around my face
like the movie i wish
you're cheating you can't get help this
is fully cheap you know where she put
it cut this cut this so i stopped 10
seconds
this i know i know i didn't
did it in time it like a lighter
but massive yeah just you like turn the
gas on and then this is like the thing
that ignites the spark
you push it sometimes it doesn't work
push the red in and then you can change
the size of the flame
and if you squeeze this it shoots a
little more
like the trigger pretty cool but it
sticks up the entire house
easy it's my it's my uh my uh my little
panda
panda safe i think here do you guys have
a coin let me show you how this works
actually almost everything in my house
is something i bought because it's a dog
thank you check this out put a coin
right here
and then let me watch
panda comes up
yeah this is great i have a lot of time
on my hands
[Music]
hot pockets it's pretty good i had
nothing
i had nothing oh no
[Music]
this is like super nostalgic
this is my first car i drove out to um
la with
and it's really cool because shelby and
sandy painted this
and you could even see one of the rims
are missing it was like a really beat
down car
and this door stopped opening and it was
really cool because it was like a
35 hour drive and it was like like a
serious journey to
to start our new life here in la so i i
love this and this is one of my favorite
cars i've ever owned it's a 2004 turtle
corolla
with cloth seats like they don't make
cars like that anymore and those are the
softest to sit in the cloth seats
never take those for granted those are
the best thank you guys for doing that
with me that was a blast
um make sure to catch me on the kelly
clarkson show where we're gonna have
even more fun
[Music]